[Música]
o pessoal bom dia 3 vamos contar um
pouquinho de 18 anos de histórias é em
18 minutos
então o tema hoje aqui é o caminho da
execução é vou contar um pouco do que a
gente acabou é realizando é parabéns
pela palestra muito bacana ea gente tem
várias muito em comum é como por exemplo
a coragem o empreendedorismo e
principalmente uma coisa que eu acredito
que eu abro mão que são os valores é
então é eu quero começará a contar a
história de uma é pequena empresa é de
lavanderia que a gente iniciou o nome é
love braz
a gente iniciou essa empresa é no sul de
santa catarina é basicamente 20 anos
atrás e ao longo desses anos a gente
acabou consolidando essa empresa é
fizemos várias aquisições fizemos 30
aquisições em um período de 36 meses e
essa empresa se transformou na maior
empresa é de lavanderia da américa
latina em 16 estados distrito federal 70
filiais 4.500 colaboradores é é a gente
começou a atuar no segmento de
frigoríficos e depois a gente acabou
migrando para o segmento de hotéis e
hospitais então você imagina o que cada
hotel que vocês ficam cada hospital que
alguém algum parente fica é que tem um
lençol tem uma toalha é tem uma fronha
isso aí a gente acabou vendo nisso aí
uma oportunidade de criar é um negócio e
aqui da coisa que eu acredito muito que
é a criação da cultura dentro de uma
companhia é ea criação da cultura da
companhia ela passa é pela sua missão
pela sua visão e pelos seus valores que
são que são os valores os valores são
aquilo que a gente não abre mão aquilo
que a gente acredita e aquilo que a
gente
tenta trazer todo o time é dentro é do
mesmo projeto dentro da mesma cultura
então qual é a nossa missão era muito
claro criar e estabelecer uma relação
muito e duradoura de confiança junto aos
nossos clientes assegurando com nossa
competência compromisso melhor serviço
crescimento e rentabilidade do negócio
então olhando também para o lado do
nosso acionista é e orgulho dos
colaboradores né é fazer parte então aí
nós temos um tripé entre cliente
acionista e colaborador é que a gente
precisa manter um negócio em pé para
manter o negócio é a gente tem que
acabar olhando para o lado de todas as
pessoas
a nossa visão seremos a maior e melhor
lavanderia é dos na américa latina e
sendo três somente reconhecida pela sua
participação na vida das pessoas e os
nossos valores que a gente é tentava
trazer as nossas é pessoas é pra dentro
do mesmo sonho pra dentro do mesmo
projeto olhando pra mesma coisa
a visão ea atitude de dono liderança
pelo exemplo austeridade encantamento do
cliente
uma coisa que foi falado aqui
simplicidade inconformismo e humildade
então a gente acredita nessas coisas e
todas as pessoas que a gente trouxe para
dentro do projeto agente também pensava
e trazer para essa mesma linha de
valores é as diretrizes eram muito
simples é crescimento é tanto orgânico
como pura aquisição rentabilidade e
sustentabilidade ea nossa visão estava
sempre ali né será maior e melhor
empresa do segmento de lavanderia
é o que isso fez né isso fez com que a
gente de 2004 até 2016 é fizesse um
crescimento de 53% ao ano na média isso
é muito difícil mas isso só é possível
se todas as pessoas estiverem alinhadas
dentro dos mesmos valores porque se a
gente não conquistar mentes e corações
ninguém faz nada sozinho é sim né
totalmente impossível de realizar um
sonho
cultura nossa então vocês vêem que a
gente falou é de fusão e aquisição
a gente falou de cultura é agora nós
estamos falando de estrutura era uma
estrutura muito simples né então é é
alguém pode imaginar é que tinha lá
palma uma longa e extensa linha é de
pessoas não então a gente tinha lhe uma
uma área de recursos humanos uma área
financeira uma área de vendas e uma área
de operação que é basicamente aquilo que
a empresa é precisa agora aqui é uma
coisa que pra nós é muito cara que é o
cuidado com as pessoas então a gente é
através desse programa é dado bom a
gente tinha como nós temos uma
lavanderia um negócio muito crítico a
temperatura produto químico áreas
molhadas áreas úmidas é então nós temos
um programa muito é rigoroso de
segurança do trabalho para a gente poder
cuidar dos nossos talentos na então uma
empresa sem talento não vai
absolutamente lugar nenhuma empresa sem
dinheiro e com muito talento eu tenho
certeza que ela vai prosperar uma
empresa com muito dinheiro com sem
talento e com muito dinheiro tenho
certeza que o camarada não vai pra
frente então o que a gente tinha tinha
bastante alento dentro da nossa
companhia e agente através de um
programa muito rigoroso de saúde
segurança e meio ambiente a gente
cuidava dos nossos talentos porque toda
vez que a gente cuida do um próximo e
esse próximo vai fazer nada mais do que
nos retribuir é com produtividade é com
resiliência um competência com
comprometimento na então a nossa empresa
sempre teve uma visão muito clara é de
que cuidar do talento era super
importante treinamentos na então as
coisas que a gente sempre é fácil é nós
temos numa nova empresa que a gente vai
chegar aqui nessa empresa também a gente
tem um workshop é coordenado por mim
pessoalmente todas as segundas-feiras às
seis horas da manhã em que a gente
discute é durante uma hora com todo o
nosso time gerencial algum tema o tema
do momento hoje a gente está discutindo
aquele livro de eli gold rádio chamado a
meta então é todas e e como é que a
gente faz isso cada unidade é toda
semana prepara é uma apresentação é pra
poder compartilhar isso com todos os
times então treinamento é valorizar as
pessoas e trazer o que os talentos que a
gente é tem é possam dar o que tem de
melhor
nós também é bastante é bastante por
bastante importante
agora vou contar o que aconteceu com as
empresas empresa acabou é sendo vendida
no ano passado foi a maior transação é
de lavanderia da história do mundo então
é foi um sucesso então teve um início
teve um meio e teve um fim
então foi uma história que a gente
iniciou a gente acreditou e
principalmente a gente entregou foi
vendida por uma multinacional francesa
que mora em empresas de lavanderia do
mundo é e o pessoal está super feliz com
a aquisição estão indo muito bem é no
brasil claro o brasil não é para
amadores isso a gente sabe todos aqui
muito bem
é mas é com a cultura que a gente criou
dentro da companhia é essa cultura ela é
ajuda muito a ace transpor nessas os os
pontos aí é complicado que o nosso país
acaba trazendo no meio desse caminho da
avibrás a gente foi o jogo é fundar uma
outra companhia que é uma empresa de
produção de ovos
então a gente iniciou no mato grosso é
essa empresa era é especializada em
produção é de ovos férteis
então a gente começou a história lá e
dessa e dessa forma isso aí começou lá
em 2006 é depois da do desse trabalho
que a gente fez em cima
ambos férteis a gente acabou adquirindo
uma empresa é em santa catarina e essa
empresa é produzir os pintinhos é
pintinhos de um dia né que depois de 35
40 dias viram o frango que a gente acaba
consumindo nas nossas casas e
recentemente a gente acabou se motivando
né com esse negócio porque a gente viu
que a gente tinha uma cultura muito
forte é tinha bastante talento dessa
companhia dentro dessa companhia ea
gente acabou como começando a fazer de
novo fusões e aquisições né ea gente
começou a adquirir empresas do segmento
de ovo de mesa de ovo comercial que esse
ovo que a gente consome nas nossas casas
esse ano a gente já comprou três
empresas ea gente tem é qualquer coisa
em torno de 15 empresas do nosso
pipeline que a gente está olhando está
conversando né está super animado em de
novo fazer uma história de consolidação
a empresa também ela é a maior
exportadora de ovo fértil do brasil é a
gente exporta para diversos países
méxico arábia saudita é emirados árbes é
a áfrica américa do sul e alguns países
da alemanha também né então é imagina
que um a vida útil de um ovo é são sete
dias e eu tenho que chegar no interior
da arábia saudita consegue com menos de
sete dias
então isso para realizar precisa de
execução
se não tiver execução o negócio acaba
não acontecendo de novo uma estrutura né
aquilo que a gente acredita é a mesma
fórmula linha de bolo negócio muito
simples né
sem muita invenção de invenção de moda é
valores nessi vocês analisar os valores
são muitos parecidos com os da outra
empresa visam a atitude do dono em
conformismo austeridade foco no cliente
simplicidade e aqui nesse caso como a
gente lida com é animais vivos nos é
muito importante
da biossegurança então a partir do
momento e traz todas as pessoas para
dentro das mesmas crenças dentro dos
mesmos valores
a vida fica muito mais fácil né porque a
não ficar discutindo e perdendo tempo
com aquilo que a gente não acredita
então por que acredita nisso não eu
acredito nisso então vamos lá tanto no
time né então cultura dentro de uma
companhia é fundamental a empresa sem
cultura é difícil né pode ter caso de
sucesso eu não conheço muitos não é o
nosso caso
então aqui é se vocês a pensar em tudo
aquilo que a gente é conversou até agora
a gente vai chegar numa fórmula é que eu
acredito como uma forma fundamental para
o sucesso a estratégia ela tem que estar
bem definida a onde que a gente define a
nossa estratégia a quem a gente esquecer
como que a gente vai querer chegar lá
quanto dinheiro a gente vai é gastar e
ter para chegar nesse e realizar esse
esse projeto à execução gente execução é
fundamental não adianta fazer o melhor
planejamento do mundo se alguém não
acordar cedo e botar a barriga na frente
do tanque e descer do salto alto e ir lá
fazer um negócio acontecer eu conheço
muito aluno bom com excelentes
potenciais e não tem em execução os
estados unidos têm uma é uma estatística
que diz o seguinte que 66% dos
superdotados
eles estão trabalhando em lanchonete
hoje é o varrendo o chão ou em caixa do
supermercado nada relevante em relação à
capacidade intelectual deles porque
porque é porque eles se acostumaram na
cabeça deles tudo foi tão fácil na vida
deles que eles vão precisar ralar
então tem que ter muita inspiração
mas mais do que inspiração também tem
que ter transpiração que se não tiver
execução eu não conheço fórmula de
sucesso que não passou por uma execução
muito forte
criar uma cultura é isso é importante é
o gasto hoje é 40 50%
o meu tempo trabalhando a cultura das
pessoas trabalhando o coxa
vamo trazer as pessoas para a mesma
página vai as contratações das pessoas
que são ligadas a mim a gente faz muitas
vezes 567 entrevistas para ter certeza
de que aquela pessoa vai se enquadrar
dentro da nossa realidade então é melhor
perder um pouquinho de tempo é
entrevistando conversando com a pessoa é
dando os limites é estressando aonde que
essa pessoa pode quer chegar dentro da
companhia do que depois de perder 2 e 3
anos dentro do qual essa pessoa dentro
da sua empresa pode chegar à conclusão
na frente que essa pessoa não serve pra
gente na então a questão cultural dentro
de uma companhia é fundamental eu
acredito nisso ea gente faz isso exerce
essa atividade o tempo inteiro
a estrutura né a estrutura pó como que a
gente fez um bom planejamento a gente
tem em execução ea gente criou uma
cultura forte então qual é a estrutura
quem que vai fazer o que é é tem que ter
uma estrutura muito simples não adianta
complicar né sic k quanto mais
complicado fica a estrutura mais difícil
fica todos os pontos acima é começa a
ter sobreposição aí dificulta a questão
cultural dificulta a execução é um
desastre a estratégia então esses quatro
pontos aí eles são fundamentais e mais
duas coisas que eu também acredito eu
que também utilizem todos os nossos
projetos
um é a questão dos talentos nós
precisamos de talentos a gente precisa
atrair talento a gente precisa ser um
ambiente propício é pra trazer o talento
pra dentro da nossa vida é ea questão
das fusões e aquisições do que uma fusão
aquisição ela traz pra dentro da gente
quando uma fusão com uma aquisição é bom
quando a gente dentro da nossa estrutura
consegue fazer com aquele novo ativo
é melhor ea gente acaba gerando valor
nesse negócio que a gente fez
qual é a vantagem disso aí a vantagem
disso é que a gente ganha muito tempo o
crescimento orgânico é muito doloroso
ele é muito lento eo crescimento por
fusão e aquisição ele é muito mais
rápido agora pra funcionar precisa das
outras práticas não dá pra sair é tu vai
comprar o negócio e aí tu pior aquele
negócio de destruir riqueza do comprou o
negócio melhorou aquele negócio criou
riqueza então nós estamos aí com a
cabeça sempre em gerar valor é sempre
dentro daqueles pontos gerar valor para
o acionista é gerar valor para o cliente
e gerar valor de uma forma exatamente
igual importante para o colaborador que
faz parte dessa história junto com a
gente é meu muito obrigado é como eu
falei tratar de 18 anos de história em
18 minutos é um grande desafio mas é
hora portanto trouxe isso para nós ea
gente aceitou é e um bom dia a todos aí
[Aplausos]